>> ALFRED: So, I'm Derrick Alfred (ph) from
the New York Times. I'm a Software Architect
there. And we use Google on a number of places.
We've used the Maps API for our real estate
and travel sections. We've used CSE to power
our site search. We've also more recently
used some of the data APIs around portable
contacts to do a social graph import for our
TimesPeople application.
>> So, you chose to use the Google APIs, the
AJAX APIs, tell us a bit about how you came
to this decision.
>> ALFRED: So, one of the reasons we wanted
to use the Google APIs is user familiarity.
So, people are really used to the Google Maps
experience. They know the look and feel. Has
wide adoption. So, it's a comfortable fit
for our users. It has great coverage and it
is easy to work with, so we've been able to
do a lot of interesting overlays that really
complement the data and the journalism that
we do on top of it.
>> So, as developers, we really value being
able to share war stories and lessons, technical
challenges, tell us about one particularly
difficult period of development phase on how
you approached the technical challenge.
>> ALFRED: So, recently, we have a social
layer that puts on top of nytimes.com called
TimesPeople. And one of our challenges has
been importing social graph and so we've used
the Google Contacts API and the newer implementation
of portable contacts. So, I think the real
difficulty for us has been or the challenge
has been the kind of evolving standard around
that and so we were really excited to see
Google adopt portable contacts. And so, luckily
for us, we actually just--we didn't operate
fast enough but the way we solve some of our
technical problems is that we waited long
enough for Google to embrace the standard
and allow us to reuse some existing code that
we already had, so that was really exciting
for us.
>> So, what are some of the benefits to your
app of using the APIs?
>> ALFRED: So, I think our TimesPeople social
application really benefits from using portable
contacts and since that Google Contacts and
Gmail have such a wide adoption, it enables
people to get up on our TimesPeople social
layer much easier. So, by importing those
friends, we're able to start using TimesPeople
and be a lot more productive from the get-go.
>> Has using the APIs reduced the amount of
work for you?
>> ALFRED: I think definitely using the APIs
has reduced the amount of work. In some ways
it's not just reduced the amount of work but
it's made things possible where it might not
have been possible otherwise. So, if there's
certain things that we, you know, might not
have--ever have done in terms of our real
estate and showing maps and where things are
and putting the overlays on that--without
something like Google Maps, I'm not sure how
we would have done it.
>> What kinds of features of were made possible
by having access to produce APIs?
>> ALFRED: So, some of the interesting features
we've done with Google Maps around our travel
and destination sites, we're able to kind
of plot a lot more stuff and show the same
content that we have kind of in a list or
tabular form actually laid out geographically
and it really enables--users get a sense of
how to start to plan their trips and think
about the places they're going to visit. So,
it's really greatly and rich start travel
site.
>> What are some of the features you're planning
to implement to your application?
>> ALFRED: Well, we continue to look at all
the Google APIs as they come out and trying
to figure out which ones we can leverage to
take advantage of. And so, I think, things
that are around the social--open social stuff
are really interesting and as we see some
of the more advanced features around CSE coming
on board with the customized search, I think
there is great potential for us to kind of
leverage some of the newer stuff there as
well.